hey i'm kevin from drawoff and today
i've gathered nine other artists from
all across the internet to reimagine
spongebob squarepants
in their own unique styles let's check
them out well hello there my name is
christian i'm an abstract artist from
nebraska
is my face glowing yes
it's my two dollar moisturizer from
walmart what i plan on doing in this
drawing is i want to go a little bit
more literal with the actual
shape of a sponge well i went in with an
oil pastel sketch
of course in yellow because spongebob is
yellow
the tools i used of course oil pastel
they're my favorite
um some are very hard and translucent
some are very creamy and opaque
i do like to start off with the more uh
translucent end off with the creamier
one
it adds a better blending effect
especially when i get to
the scratchy scratch y'all i love to use
a little screwdriver to do these little
scratches
it adds some texture and it also has
like a 3d effect when you look at it
super close
my name is agustina and i'm a character
designer what i'm gonna do first
is i'm gonna do a very very rough sketch
just to get the idea right you don't
have to worry about making the
picture pretty at first it doesn't
matter you just need to
get the idea right what i like about
drawing digitally is that you can
play with the shapes a lot
and push the pose if you want with the
selection tool
i always thought of spongebob as one of
us so guessing that he's stuck in his
pineapple just like we are stuck
in our houses so i thought of
drawing him very late at night scrolling
through the internet
so once we have this very rough sketch
what i'm gonna do next
is create a new layer and
start working on top of this one
probably if you eat a bag of chips you
will want something sweet after so i'm
gonna grow a couple snacks there
hi my name is natalie cherry i am a
watercolor and sketch artist from
south africa i focus mainly on
watercolors right now
with a little bit of line work so i
chose
a version of him where it looked like he
was excited
and moving because i am a dancer as well
i used a black micron pen to outline
and then i do a base layer and in this
base layer
i like to add the shadow the dark and
the light so that when i build on top of
that it just creates more depth and then
i apply
another layer which adds some contrast
and then the
final layer i add white and black
i didn't have a lot of i guess
mentorship i watched a lot of youtube i
watched a lot of
instagram videos and i read a bunch so
the other thing that
is quite fun is finding artists that are
on a similar level to you on instagram
and seeing what they're doing and
kind of trying it out yourself hi i'm
kenny
i'm an illustrator from laguna beach
california and today i'm going to be
drawing spongebob i
always start on a toned canvas
so i just lay down a basic color and
then i get sketching
um and while i'm sketching some of the
main things i'm trying to think about
are tangents so making sure lines aren't
touching where i don't want them to
touch
most of my digital art i use the crayon
tool in photoshop to give my art kind of
like a fuzzy
like warm childlike feeling to it
something that really inspires me about
spongebob in my own art actually is how
all the characters are like flat color
they're
you know just smooth looking and then
the backgrounds are these beautiful
like whimsical paintings that have a lot
of texture and you can
see all the brush strokes in them so i
tried to pull
that from the show into my piece today
hi there everybody my name is michaela
moore i live in virginia beach virginia
i am a character artist today in this
reimagining
i am drawing spongebob wearing street
fashion
so um i went ahead and i whipped up a
thumbnail
i enjoy starting off with thumbnails
simply because it just
allows me to get out all my ideas and
let me choose the best one
to go with so what i want to make sure i
get in
are some very interesting shapes
and make some good use of the
negative space and the positive space
the more
contrasting shapes you have the more
interesting your design is
now that i'm done with this it is time
to go on to my favorite part
coloring and shading hey everyone my
name is jasmine and i'm the founder of
get cake delay
a pancake artist based in los angeles
california today we're going to be
reimagining spongebob as pancake art
personally i'm really excited for this
opportunity i feel like as soon as they
emailed me i
knew i was ready for this it's like i've
been waiting for this my entire life
what i usually do is i always start in
the middle
of their face and then i create the
outline afterwards and work my way out
some of the challenges that i experience
while making this pancake where
the hands i'm really bad with making
hands even
cartoon hands for some reason hi my name
is clarissa reese i'm a visual artist in
costa mesa california
and i specialize in painting and drawing
to start
i do a rough drawing and pencil um
just to get everything laid out once
that's done then i erase most of it
so that i can see it and work from it
next
i did the background so i did a wash of
blue ink
and then i added some bikini bottom
flowers
once that was all dry then i focused on
spongebob
i took my watercolors and gave him some
color and then i let that dry for a
little while
after i took my pen and added some
definition and texture to the drawing
portion of it
i made a few mistakes just by
smearing the watercolor um but that
happens
and if i were to do it again i would
probably
would just erase more of the lines at
the beginning
okay so for my version of spongebob i'm
going to be drawing digitally
on my trusty wacom cintiq in adobe
photoshop and
my idea is to reimagine spongebob as
kind of a
huge underwater robot similar to
wally or big brother from bioshock
so i started off with a couple of quick
sketches using a blue pencil brush now
using blue
is a holdover from my print days because
light blue doesn't typically show up in
photographs or photocopies once i was
happy with my sketch i used a thick
black
dead weight brush to ink the major forms
and outlines
and then i went in with a thinner black
line for the details
i did all the straight lines freehand
because even though he's a robot i
wanted the drawing to still have an
organic feel and because i'm very lazy
for the colors i stuck to spongebob's
original color scheme but i desaturated
everything to give it a more
real world look i used his eyes as these
two big dramatic light sources and i
adjusted the background and the shadows
to match
finally added some texture and some
details and a little bit of color
correction in order to sell the whole
underwater scene okay hey i'm sammy june
this is my dad doc hi
and he is kind of an amazing inventor
has been my whole life and he just like
whipped this thing out for me made of
what's it made of abs sheet
for those of you who know that is um i
it's like
plastic plastic thanks for our ipads to
be able to draw so we just
put the harness thing on and then
put it up against you with this pipe
and it hooks on and then you just fit
your ipad in and it even has a little
charger in the back like who does this
my dad does this all right dad so
my first i did two because i didn't love
my first one
and this was my first one
[Music]
so i just was like i think i'm gonna do
a different one i like it though
oh thanks so my second one i
i used the same face from this one and i
just brought it over
and i did a different shaped sponge and
then i decided
to give him my style because he usually
wears
a bow tie and so i gave him a bolo tie
and
and this is this is a zipper yeah i gave
him
pants he's wearing pants and
um and the kneecaps yeah really cute
yeah i gave him kneecaps
purple shoes yeah i've made him
non-binding that's very good
thank you mine's not quite that creative
no let's see it
okay are you kidding that's amazing
but it's not creative oh my gosh
how do you do this did you whip this out
in like 10 minutes
i think it was 25 minutes 25 minutes
mine took me two days
after like flipping the pancake i was
really pleasantly surprised at how
good it came out in my family we would
call it the one
it feels definitely like it's one of my
better pancakes and i'm really proud of
how it came out
even though it's a very sad picture i
had tons of fun while
drawing it and i hope you had fun while
watching it thank you
gracias ciao i really like how he's
turned out
i like making the jellyfish look all
shiny and sparkly
and spongebob's expression is so cute
so i'm really happy with it i did have a
lot of fun doing this
because spongebob is just
quite a vibrant happy little thing
and it was fun to paint something that
lives under water
because it goes with watercolor very
much
i really love how this came out he's got
his
gary theme a backpack he's got his jelly
fishing gear
krabby patty pen on his tie krusty krab
hat
jellyfish on his pants there's a lot
going on even his watch like
patrick themed because it's pink and
green i like the final piece
it's definitely still recognizably
spongebob
but it has my style in it so i'm pretty
pleased with it
i like how my spongebob turned out one
of the things i love about drawing
robots is all the little details that
you can put into it now is it nightmare
fuel
probably but do i love them yeah i think
i did pretty well especially kind of in
the face area
the nose was also a little bit
challenging but overall
i love how it turned out i think it
looks pretty cool i love the colors
and also the scratchy scratches um
yeah i think that's it
you